does the black moon howl
no
not yet
see the boy he was born in a time before
names there weren't enough humans around
to need them back then he was one of a
handful occupying a coastal village
using a tongue long since dead they eked
out a simple life hunting gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications
until the hermit appeared the boy would
remember this man for eternity haggard
and thin skin weathered by time and pain
a man that emaciated walking with a long
gnarled cane that honestly looked
healthier than he did shouldn't be alive
even the boy who had scarcely seen
beyond the bounds of his village knew
that the hermit was unnatural an
aberration an anomaly
he walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for
then a few days later the black moon
howled the boys saw the village's
youngest hunter freeze one evening while
out on a walk not simply stand still but
freeze
then for an instant he became solid
black a coal statue and as soon as he'd
changed he was gone
obliterated not a trace of him remained
such is the power of the black moon it
can make any conscious being disappear
in an instant turned black then wiped
from our plane of existence never to be
seen again its choice of victims seemed
at each instance to be utterly random
but it would come for all who lived
eventually this is known to some as the
howling of the black moon later that
same night the boy found himself talking
to the hermit who asked with small
frantic eyes what he had seen when the
boy told him he let out a deep rattling
sigh
the boy curious asked him if he knew
about the nightmare he'd just witnessed
the hermit looked up he'd been the first
one in the hermit's millennia of pursuit
that had ever asked in that moment he
knew that he had found his successor in
the hunt for the death of ages the
hermit told the boy it went by many
names the great finale the pale king but
most common of all was the black moon
the entity existed beyond the veil of
our reality a creature of pure energy
though nobody could really be sure of
its true nature the hermit had been
tracking it learning about it and trying
to destroy it for thousands of years and
yet it only took him four pathetic
minutes to tell the boy everything he
knew the boy knowing still that
something about the hermit was unnatural
asked how he came to be in this position
the hermit told the boy he was the
counterbalance a kind of chosen one
destined to face and perhaps even defeat
the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility eternal life eternal
youth near physical immortality but they
will be haunted by their purpose doomed
to watch everyone they love die around
them as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite the black moon
itself the hermit in his own eyes had
failed at his duty he had grown weary
and now he needed to pass the duty of
counterbalance on to another that other
would be the boy he felt a sudden and
profound change along with the knowledge
that nothing would ever be the same
again he was no longer just the boy
now
he was the counterbalance he watched the
hermit give him a slight knot of respect
and then crumble into dust before his
eyes the boy the counterbalance looked
up at the sky and saw the stars
twinkling so bright and so beautiful
little did he know his battle with the
black moon would outlast every single
one of them does the black moon howl
not without blood the boy grew into a
man as his village aged and then died
around him decades past then centuries
then millennia tens of thousands of
years watching humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger the
entity was entropic a being of pure
randomness and chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with so-called obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year
once a month a week a day an hour a
minute a second he'd spell the end of
all conscious life a total victory for
the black moon the end of the universe
the death of ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless the counterbalance had
discovered many other things along the
way strange creatures objects with
extraordinary powers and events that
couldn't be explained with rational
science perhaps something about these
oddities these anomalies would hold the
key to defeating his timeless enemy and
it hadn't just been these objects
entities and events he'd also discovered
some truly exceptional people on his
travels minds and skills that rivaled
even his own despite his age perhaps
they would be the ones to help him win
with the 13 most brilliant and trusted
people the counterbalance ever met he
decided to form a council and from this
council they forged and directed an
organization dedicated to understanding
and counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search into darkness would yield the
answer to the black moon's downfall he
called it the scp foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title befitting of his new role
the administrator and even the black
moon itself was given a moniker in hopes
of robbing it of some of its frightening
power
scp-001
does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now 1987. the scp
foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity while there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new global
information network their top minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known as the singular conceptual
bunker which may one day come in handy
for combating the extra dimensional
entity directly but the most valuable
piece of information they ever gathered
about the black moon was this it
couldn't howl when it was being watched
the very act of engaged observation
defanged it the problem is how can you
observe something that doesn't
technically exist inside your own
reality in order to pull this off the
foundation would need to get extremely
creative thankfully creative solutions
to strange problems are the foundation
specialty flash forward to 1993 enter dr
moto a brilliant young scientist and
conceptual engineer working for the scp
foundation with the administrator's
consultation he started the key project
an arm of the wider project oromastes
the umbrella initiative for using
modified anomalous objects in the battle
against the black moon
the goal of the key project was
relatively simple if people couldn't
observe the black moon directly then the
foundation could make proxies of the
black moon that could be observed almost
like a kind of voodoo doll these new
anomalies would only need to satisfy
three criteria the inability to operate
when being observed a hostility to
conscious life and the ability to end
conscious life of their own volition
when not being observed through
conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory dr moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted escape by barging
through site-01 the center for
anti-black moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 0.2 seconds
almost all of moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientists felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project dr moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame and the guilt was too much for dr
moto he left a note in his office
reading we've been looking at nothing
i'm sorry administrator i failed you sir
moto's corpse was later found in the
sculpture's temporary containment
chamber his neck snapped the key project
was in summary shut down and it's one
surviving creation transported to site
19 in late 1993 where it was designated
as scp-173
another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counterbalance to
the black moon science marched on the
scp foundation marched on but all this
progress
all this power was nothing against the
incomprehensible influence of scp-001
the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year 3156
when the foundation launched the seek
project under the support of project
oromastes as more and more people were
wiped out in frequent obliteration
events the administrator became
painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the black moon problem wouldn't be
found on earth using state-of-the-art
technology with a little help from the
anomalous the scp foundation began work
on an autonomous space-faring vessel
that could search the stars for the key
to the black moon's destruction it was
an awe-inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator cryogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches seek was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets seeked arrived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snow storms when
zeke's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet
seemed to indicate that the black moon
was responsible for the destruction of
the planet's civilization causing so
many obliteration events that the
remaining survivors went mad from the
fear and stress
leading to mass death in the ensuing
chaos the next planet was discovered
centuries later in the year 3499
while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface of flaming mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior planet they'd
been driven extinct by black moon
obliteration events a century before the
sikh even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in 3764
and was the most fruitful of the three
discoveries this planet was hyper
advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling megacities with records and
technology over a thousand years ahead
of earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the scp foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all sikh found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen the craft
was immediately instructed to collect
the survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codenamed saged was returned to earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious state the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waived this duty passed it on
sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is sheb
the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual engineers the
administrator replied victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked sage asked him what good victory
would do him then rather than say it
aloud he replied with a thought sage
paused and said i see how blasphemous of
you hopefully it works after this the
administrator proceeded to the singular
conceptual bunker and entered it leaving
instructions for the foundation to be
run by a newly formed o5 council in his
indefinite absence thousands of years
later in the year 5011 sage spoke one
more time repeating the words hopefully
hopefully before turning solid black and
disappearing the black moon had claimed
one more victim but billions more had
gone in the interim the administrator
had no more answers to give at least no
more answers that anyone but him would
understand he was inside the singular
conceptual bunker now loaded into a
device known as tome an experimental
memorial module meant to pick up and
record all the last messages of every
dying civilization across the universe
when the time finally came all he could
do was wait and wait was exactly what we
did does the black moon howl
yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and tome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies across the universe were
obliterated by the black moon back in
the year 73-29
so so
so long ago but some of the final
messages of fear panic and distress
still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here
we require assistance there's it's it's
taking people every day we need help
there's barely anyone left we need help
hello
hello
cabal zero nine four three we have
abandoned the false flesh we have
abandoned the false flesh the shepherd's
crook broken neath my knee cabal zero
nine four three come on zero nine four
three forgive us forgive us
we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's i have to go now respond first
convenience
situation developing require additional
resources my fault your fault our fault
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault afro remember right now now
rip my brain out now and a small child
the last on earth simply asking hello
into an indifferent microphone but the
administrator had to wait as the
singular conceptual bunker became the
solitary conceptual bunker he was the
last conscious being in the universe and
still he needed to wait as the stars
went dark outside only when there was
nothing outside but black was it finally
time for the counterbalance's long game
to play off there was nothing left of
our universe the only thing here was the
scb and the black moon itself with
everything else gone the black moon only
had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this
this doesn't make sense how can the
black moon an entity beyond our
dimension beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance
the administrator he said
well there you are certainly took your
time can i pour you a little something
this only served to increase the black
moon's confusion it had form here dark
smoke compressed into a vaguely humanoid
shape it could speak it could think none
of this made any sense the being that
had just wiped out all conscious life
and seen the very death of the universe
was truly and utterly confused the
administrator just seemed to be enjoying
himself preparing for a confrontation
hundreds of billions of years in the
making the singular conceptual bunker or
perhaps the singular containment bunker
was a truly ingenious creation a place
of pure ideas where everything inside
was on the same level here there were no
immortals no gods just ideas on the same
level playing field and it was time for
the black moon's idea to come to an end
it was a trap and the entire universe
was the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and unleashed both
barrels into the black moon's chest the
creature took the hit and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster's
relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he beat the monster over the
head with it until its grip loosened and
he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is
this place is only information
there's nothing else out there not even
matter the universe closed its doors a
long time ago this place can go from
information back to matter with just the
press of a button
let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing for a second it
looks as though he might fall but he
doesn't instead he slams the button on
the jukebox and with a relieve laugh
says
let there be light and there was
light now go check out scp-001
which is the real zero zero one and
scp-001
ex a good boy to unravel more of the
many mysteries of the legendary scp-001